bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv pour ce championnat du
monde de 2014 annonce qu'arsène la
revanche la revanche après que carsen et
conquis le titre la dernière fois face à
rennes on and on a réussi à gagner le
tournoi des candidats juste derrière un
exploit extraordinaire puisqu'il fallait
avoir le mental pour pouvoir revenir et
à se qualifier de nouveau pour essayer
de reconquérir son titre c'est possible
il ya eu déjà eu des cas dans l'histoire
mais sûr on est champions du monde a
réussi à reconquérir son titre juste
après avoir perdu bas c'était notamment
bozzini qu'un tout simplement et karpov
a failli le faire
en 87 puisque à séville le fameux match
de séville face à kasparov
eh bien ils menaient d'un point avant la
dernière partie et ça s'est joué
vraiment à un cheveu que karpov puisse
lui aussi reconquérir son titre et avant
on a eu aussi aller qui ne faut pas
oublier les kin qui bien sûr avait perdu
son titre face à max hoff dans les
années 30 et a ensuite réussi dans un
match revanche à le reprendre au fameux
hollandais max hoff qui en suit donc
était aussi devenu le président de la
fédération internationale des échecs
dans les années 70 c'est notamment
c'était lui qui a remis le titre de
championne mandat bobby fischer qui
s'est fait donc sacré par un autre
champion du monde ce qui est toujours
bien sûr agréable donc alors on n'en est
pas là on est en 2014
la lignée des champions demande continue
car ce n est le seizième champion du
monde classique depuis
steinitz en 1886 kasparov était le 13e
kramnik donc a ravi le titre en 2000
pour devenir le 14e allende ensuite a
réussi à devenir le 15e en battant
cramique et donc on se retrouve
maintenant avec arsène le norvégien le
viking qui est bien montre un jeu tout à
fait nouveau tout à fait étonnant je
dirais pour pour l'époque puisque c'est
un joueur qui va plutôt chercher les
points dans les positions de finale dans
l'est dans la position après l'ouverture
cherche pas forcément obtenir un
avantage dès l'ouverture et mis à jouer
d ouverture peu connus ou un peu
critique et et a montré une supériorité
dans le fond de jeu et la fin de partie
où il est extrêmement précis et il
rappelle en cela très certainement le
champion du monde cubain bien sûr rossé
raul capablanca qui lui aussi était
connu pour tirer d'opposition
apparemment plate nuls et bien des
avantages qu'ils accumulent et petit à
petit pour finir par l'emporter
là où la plupart des joueurs font plutôt
donc des parties nulles or cette
première partie avant d'aller blanc et
ça c'est important puisque donc dans la
suite du championnat et bien bien sûr ça
va jouer le fait d'avoir les blancs en
premier et on va voir tout de suite ce
qu'ont choisi les joueurs comme
ouverture alors un an démarre cette
première partie donc avec le coût des
quatre voilà donc un coût des quatre
roues mais sur classique 4 ou des quatre
les coups classiques en début de partie
donc avalé v6 pourquoi pas deux car c
est donc jusque là tout va bien c'est 4
et là tout de suite surprise g62 carsen
et s'attendait peut-être pas à anand
puisqu'on peut rentrer maintenant alors
soit dans une estonienne soit dans une
soie dans une cruelle avec le fou g7
donc qui va se tenir sur le fameux fiant
kétou essayer de contrôler la cette
diagonale ici cette diagonale de cases
noires centrale où le foot est actif au
revoir ça plus tard alors qu'elle a
laissé trois des cinq voilà donc sa
lassitude grünfeld ainsi on si les noirs
avaient voulu jouer l'estonienne et
j'aurais joué fou g7 tout de suite donc
des cinq en contre attaque directement
au centre on va voir l'idée de cette
variante après c'est prendre des cinq
cavaliers prendre des cinq souvent ici
les blancs joubert tout simplement eu 4
le pion ici va sur la caisse de 4
lecavalier des cinq ici va plutôt
essayer les flèches sinon ça vient trop
le cahier des 5 va se sentent sans doute
s'est changé en c3 et après la reprise
du pion on a un centre fort avec des
pions qui peuvent être ainsi trois des
quatre 4 centres forts que les noir
brossé de pilonner avec le fouler cette
année le coup c5 qui attaquent ce centre
si le pion prend évidemment il y aurait
fou prend avec échec ce serait une
catastrophe
donc voilà c'est le genre d'idées qu'on
a dans la grünfeld on laisse les blancs
s'installer au centre mais évidemment
pas pour les laisser s'installer
durablement mais pour le contre attaquer
immédiatement un jeu volontairement en
laissant volontairement donc les blancs
occuper le centre la food & 2 ici à
nantes joue un coup pas du tout
classique voilà il joue pas le coup et
quatre classiques y joue une variante
peut-être un peu moins connu un peu
moins standard est peut-être très
certainement parce que justement il
n'avait pas prévu
que carsen joue cette ouverture donc
dans une première partie comme ça ils
préfèrent ne pas rentrer directement
peut-être dans des variantes plus
pointus il joue quelque chose de plus
peut-être plus solide plus classique
c'est à dire que maintenant si les noirs
prennent en c3 peut-on prendre du fou et
puis il ya plus de possibilités pour les
noirs d'attaquer le centre aussi
facilement mais bon les blancs sont
moins forts aussi puisqu'on a moins de
pions centre foulée c'est donc ça c'est
classique
e4 on attaque le cavalier est là alors
on peut peut-être mettre le cap et un
bep 6 mai c'est un peu passif bien sûr
puisque les blancs dans ce cas là
j'aurais fouet trois peut-être ou
peut-être 5 ou non peut-être des cinq
peut-être des 5
il ya d'autres possibilités mais la
bombe et qu'arsène tout simplement
choisi de nous éviter d'y réfléchir
puisqu'il fait il prend ses 3 es fou
prend voilà donc ici le pion des cas
bien sûr et bien protégé par la dame et
par le fou donc ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de soucis particuliers et la partie peut
donc suivre son cours mais dans une
variante un peu un peu disons
de second tour d'amd deux dames des deux
ans mais la dame sur cases noires on
prépare la tour en d1 pourquoi pas aussi
le rock pourquoi pas l'envisager même si
il faut y réfléchir parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de pions devant le roi blanc
mais bon on peut on peut envisager de
faire le grand roque et de mettre le roi
blanc bien voire même plus tard un c'est
possible aussi en tout cas on libère le
passage là tout en contrôle le fou ces
trois ou six ans on défende cavalli c6
regardez donc la même idée de connaître
une fête général mais si on sort les
pièces et puis on attaque un ici vers le
centre voilà on met le maximum de
pression sur le pion central kabis iii
c'est logique on défend le pion tout en
sortant des pièces et la foulée quatre
là aussi sortie logique du fou ces huit
en g4 on attaque le cavaliere 3 et donc
si on attaque le khalife 3 bien sûr mais
en contrepartie de cette de cet échange
ici on aura une pression accrue sur des
4 1 puis qu'on aura éliminé un défenseur
donc là il faut que les blancs trouve
une idée quelque chose donc très simple
évidemment le plus simple c'est de jouer
des 5 c'est ce que fait un angle on joue
des cinq maintenant plus problème sur
des quatre en plus on propose un échange
de fou on n'est pas mécontent d'échangés
se fout g7 qui est quand même puissant
et en plus un défenseur dur en noir bon
donc c'est pas forcément une mauvaise
idée mais en contrepartie on affaiblit
un peu les cases noires au centre est
sûre on peut pas tout avoir évidemment
en échange ale on a moins de contrôle
sur l'écrasement puisqu'on a les pions
maintenant sur casse blanche donc
élimination au parent à nantes du
défenseur f3 foutront g7
d'abord reprend et maintenant pions
prend et francs alors regardez
maintenant le coût du carsen cavalier e
5 et puis évidemment la menace est
cavalier ici sur la case f3 menace
évidemment une fourchette sur le roi et
la dame la fameuse fourchette royal donc
il faut évidemment
contré avec les blancs est le coup le
plus simple le plus logique le plus joli
aussi le plus en art c'est de jouer le
coup donnant bien sûr grand roque parce
que on met le roi à l'abri à plus
d'échecs et regardez le piège c'est que
si les noirs prennent en f3 au regard
des dames ses trois échecs au roi et le
cavalier perdu puisque la dame ici
contrôler la case f3 voilà donc
attention contre fourchette voilà où
logique parce que on développe ses
pièces au maximum on essaie de ne pas
perdre de temps aux échecs bien sûr est
de sortir ces pièces si en même temps on
peut créer des contrôles menace c'est
pas plus mal
ces six alors très bien joué bien sûr de
carsen puisque ces 6
si les blancs prennent en c6 on peut
envisager pourquoi pas d'échanger des
dames puis de prendre en c6 très
certainement du cavalier puisqu'on va
pas abîmer notre structure de pions il
faut rappeler ici quand il vaut mieux
éviter d'avoir un pion isolé donc là
l'idée de ces si c'est pas en cas de
prise de reprendre du plomb mais de
rependre du cavalier donc
avoir une très belle structure de pian
alors que les blancs auront pions
doubler ici
voilà donc sans doute un avantage
structurel noir un cas de prises donc
déjà difficile pour les blancs
d'envisager de prendre et ensuite la
deuxième idée pour les normes c'est
d'ouvrir les lignes parce que scipion
prendre des cinq qui est l'idée des
noirs après la tour s'est vite peut
venir avec un échec
les pièces noires se sortent facilement
finissent leur développement et les
blancs restent avec quand même un pion
doublé un sévère faut pas oublier que la
les blancs en contrepartie de leur
présence au centre bien ils ont concédé
un pion doublé donc la jolie coude d'un
land regard des dames car très fort
d'ailleurs parce que nomme c3 regardez
le cavalier il est cloué et c'est
embêtant parce que si les noirs
imaginons que les noirs défend david
d'amd si si si on défend le cavalier et
bien simplement f4 et lecavalier il peut
pas bouger puisqu'il est cloué donc le
cahier perdu donc est-ce que carsen
aurait oublié quelque chose
dames c3 et en plus regarder ce qui est
extrêmement désagréable c'est qu'on a un
vis-à-vis tour dames
donc c'est très embêtant parce que un
vis-à-vis tour dames je menace aussi
pions prince et six avec cette fois en
plus un vis-à-vis entre la tour la dame
sait c'est pas agréable
c'est à dire qu'il faudra bouger la dame
et on aura perdu un pion carsen joué six
îles par la première menace la plus
importante
injouable 6 ça y est le roi noir n'est
plus du tout sous la menace de la dame
large on protège en même temps le
cavalier c'est le coup le plus classique
le plus standard celui qu'on peut
attendre normalement dans cette position
mais il reste la deuxième menace qu'est
ce qui se passe sur pions prince et si
ce que fait ici un an et non il joue au
regard des fous s'est vite pourquoi
mais le problème écouter de prendre un
pion prince et si si si c'est qu'on peut
regarder ici puis on prend ces si si si
on regarde et effectivement on attaque
la tour d'accord pas de problème mais la
dame tout simplement va venir par
exemple sur la case b6 attaquant le pion
f2 déjà contre attaque et en cas de
prise en baisse est pour les blancs ont
simplement reprendre la dame et regarder
toutes les lignes sont ouvertes contre
le roi blanc et déjà yen menace c'est
tour c8 qui cloue la dame
donc on n'a pas envie de
de se mettre le roi en vis-à-vis déjà
intuitivement on comprend que on n'a pas
envie de se mettre l'euro un vis-à-vis
comme ça de la dame de la dame adverse
donc certainement pas donc ici car scène
joue le coût standard fou h3 qui est pas
mal puisque le regarder le fou ici alors
c'est toujours dans l'idée de fait
incarnent à nantes pardon c'est l'idée
c'est qu'on contrôle ici la case s'est
vite donc déjà on empêche ses
possibilités qu'on vient de voir
et en plus se regarder on a un oeil sur
la case du cisq et quand même casse
faible cirque en échange du pew du coup
m6 comme un bon coup pour le noir
puisque on a vu qu'ils s'en empêcher le
clouage et cette preuve défendez carlier
et on contrôle aussi une quasi sic quand
même un point un peu un peu pénible pour
pour les noirs dans cette position donc
là car c'est maintenant mons et leurs
prêts emprunts en dessin qu'il faut pas
oublier que l'idée de cars 2 car c'est
ni si c'est quand même d'ouvrir les
lignes pour essayer regarder un bon on a
quand même un vis-à-vis il ya ainsi
possible entre d'un miroir bon pour
l'instant y'a le fou mais
on sait jamais à tout moment il pourrait
y avoir une possibilité donc il faut
quand même faire attention avec les
blancs on n'aime pas trop garder le roi
ici un temps que tant que la dame est en
c3 en tout cas donc ici puis on prend
des cinq sauro les lignes c'est parti
alors là on aurait pu envisager avec les
blancs mais sûr de prendre soin avec la
tour soit avec le pion pour l'instant
tour ces 8es pas possible à cause du fou
donc on est tranquille on peut réfléchir
aux deux possibilités et un ans choisi
de prendre plutôt du pion ce qui sans
doute la meilleure solution même si
évidemment le problème c'est que
maintenant on a un pion isolé c'est à
dire que là le ce pion est tout seul
même s'il est quand même puis on sans
trace un pion fort mais on a deux pions
aussi doublé maintenant qu'ils sont un
peu tout seul mais en compensation on a
quand même pion au centre protégé par
une tour donc c'est quand même point de
fixation de l'adversaire et en plus on
peut on à cette fameuse case de 6 ou le
fou sera magnifiquement placé et qui
gênera quand même pas mal les noirs et
on peut envisager ensuite de jouer f4
pour chasser le cavalier pourquoi pas
des f5 et en cas de g5 h4 avait des
attaques contre le roi donc quand même
des possibilités ici dynamique du côté
blanc donc cavalier ici f7 de la part de
deux cars scène alors pourquoi pourquoi
qu'il y avait sept
regardez ce cavalier il a sans doute
venu veut envie de venir sur la fameuse
classe des six pourquoi parce que c'est
une fameuse c'est une case connu comme
étant une case de blocage voilà je
bloque le pion passé enfin c'est pas un
pion passé le pion avancé je bloque il
pourra plus bouger et lecavalier n'est
pas attaquable en direct par la tacc
détour ni par le fou donc il est
magnifiquement place et ils contrôlent
des cas sans pouvoir être attaqué donc
c'est sans doute sa meilleure case en
fait il replace son cavalier pour lui
trouver une meilleure case f4 c'est
l'heure du plan un peu plus vous ai dit
tout à l'heure il ya deux idées a fait
un plein idée sur ce coup et 4 1 un bon
bain j'enlève la case au sein et à cast
g5 pourquoi il ya tension est vive l'a45
aussi parce que j'attaque le fouet
nouvelle fourche peut plus venir en 6 du
coût puisque lg 5 contrôlée au cices ça
pouvait être embêtant
j'empêche ses possibilités puis je mets
le pion sur noir surtout voilà c'est
surtout ça à mon avis
ce qu'il faut retenir ici je mets le
pion sur cases noires que quand on a les
fous sur une certain couleurs de quasi
si le fouillent surface blanche mettre
les pions sur la couleur reposer ça
compte ça complète l'action des pièces
voilà le fou et complète là le contrôle
des blancs en plus ce pion la tient en
respect le pion g6 qui peut pas avancer
en gsm dont on peut envisager après par
exemple vous aussi ce des idées comme h
4 h 5 pour essayer d'ouvrir la position
du renoir bon évidemment les noirs ont
une position très saine pour l'instant
et donc ya pas de problème il faut
simplement qu'ils soient dynamiques et
la dame des six voilà donc là c'est plus
l'idée de venir le cavalier nam et une
taie lancé la dame qui attaquent ce pion
qui est venu avec 4,6 a aussi maintenant
qu'à changer
le plaignant f4 en plus à noter que sur
la présence naturelle échec et en plus
on lit les tours 1 on lit le tour donc
attention attention puisque si on bouche
l'année gonal de ce fou un d'une façon
ou d'une autre par exemple par f5
composent plus tard pour l'instant on
peut pas nier la dame ici mais si on
arrivait à boucher la des modèles de ce
fou par exemple imaginons que les blancs
jouent ou tient le coup et cinq pour
essayer de casser la structure de renoir
maintenant cavalier g5 attaque le fou
sur fuji 4 h 5 et si le football je fais
même pas sur f5 tout de suite tour s'est
vite lassée pire elle voilà sur f cell
tout simplement pour s'éviter la
d'amérique loi c'est encore plus simple
donc simplement pour rappeler qu'il faut
avoir l'oeil absolument sur cette case
s'est vite donc la dame des quatre bons
l'intérêt et de secousses et je
centralise adams qui est toujours bien
j'ai un oeil sur le pion à 4 et puis
jean lève enfin ce fils vis-à-vis
toujours un peu pénible d'un moins qu'on
n'a pas envie de laisser ça très
longtemps
est ce qu'on sait jamais ce qui peut se
passer plus tard un voile adam des
quatre et on est bien le cavalière s'est
ici à noter qu'au roi 1 quand il est
proche de son cavalier en général le cai
est un excellent défenseur
voilà c'est donc allé à côté du roi en
général défend énormément d'attaqués
très difficile d'attaquer un roi avec un
k way a coûté autour des 8
donc la bande son c'est on pourra jamais
avec les noirs à venir sur ces huit
façons ça sert plus à rien maintenant
d'envisager saps carabéen tout
simplement et c'est plutôt les blancs
qui ont essayé de venir sur la colonne
sait puisque les blancs jouent ici lefa
le fameux content apparaître à leur fou
e.cisse maintenant que la tour d uts a
été jouée c'est mieux puisque l'on peut
même pas à chasser ce fou par cavalli
des 8e tour voilà donc c'est le bon
moment peut être deux pour le jouer
regardez ce fou est bien positionné là
il surprotège le pion des 5
on ne peut envisager mais dans des
plantes pour les blancs à quoi à coup de
trois baies un tour c'est un tour c'est
3 1 doublé tour et puis on pénètre sur
la colonne c'est pourquoi pas et les
noirs la joue le coup d'un v6 alors ce
coût d'un v6 va un peu dans l'idée qu'on
vient de donner mais à nandy si je veux
un coup surprenant un peu inattendu et
sans doute il aurait dû poursuivre il
joue en fait le coût d'un des deux mais
qu'est ce qui se serait passé pour un
autre sans doute une meilleure option
aurait été de jouer dans prend b6
apprend b6 web et un suivi de tours
c'est un et on peut pas avec les noirs
empêcher tour c'est cette donc pourquoi
on n'a pas joué ça mystère ça semble
tout naturel d'autant qu'en plus on a
doublé les pions adverse ce qui compense
un tout petit peu les pions doubler ici
puisque bombes et les noirs aussi on est
bien doubler on peut venir les attaques
et être présent sur la 7e
bon ça paraissait une bonne suite hélas
non de jouer un coup un peu un peu petit
bras
c'est pas trop pourquoi il a fait ça
donc ils jouent sur la case up down et 6
il joue sur la case des deux voilà je
vous sens cass d2 qui est moins fort
c'est moins fort là il aurait dû
échanger d'autant que la dame était bien
placé en d4
pourquoi en d2 elle est pas très bien
placé c'est la dame betty scala bien
placé maintenant la saa bonnes cases
elle peut pas être chassé par le fou
peut difficilement chassés par une tour
adverse pour revenir sur la troisième
elle a un oeil sur le pion f2 voilà
pourquoi pas un oeil aussi sur b2 bon
même s'il a pour l'instant on va pas
trop comment ça pourrait servir au noir
mais elle est bien placée cette dame
alors que la dame nom des deux là ici on
demande ce qu'elle fait là quoi pour
l'instant
peut-être qu à nant d'avril dans l'idée
de jouer h45 et dans ce cas-là d'amd de
effectivement pour être bien placé
puisque on pourrait en cas de g5
envisager des prises du cavalier puis du
prix des prisons ghislaine pourquoi pas
des choses comme ça mais c'est dangereux
puisque il ya toujours cette dame qui
contrôlait de la torre fuite contre 2 ou
même dans cette idée à long terme
puisque s'est pas fait en faut plusieurs
coups bon c'est possible mais ça paraît
pas ça paraît pas idéal
et là tout simplement car scène continue
à placer ses pièces tour des six
bon je continue à bloquer pions des 5
je vais sur une case je peux pas être
attaqué j'ai un oeil sur le plus réussi
je peux envisager pourquoi pas et
pourquoi pas de le prendre ça pour et ça
pourrait être intéressant mais surtout
je perds mes cavaliers d'élite qui va
chasser sous bon même si après ce
cavalier on se demande ce qui fait un
des huit ans parce que
il est pris en c6 il est pris aussi les
prix un peu partout mais c'est embêtant
parce que qu'elle lui trouve alfonsi le
fou s'en va après on peut envisager de6
il ya un vis-à-vis tour dames donc on
pourra pas prendre du plomb et en même
en risque prend à berne le pion des 5
donc c'est quand même une menace une
brume la st à cause du vis-à-vis tour
dames ici cavale et des 8 suivi de six
peut être extrêmement menaçant donc la
tour e un jeu sur protège le fou donc en
cas de prise en si je pourrais prendre
éventuellement de la tour car les dés
vite voilà donc en attaque se fout et là
maintenant et 5 est donc là ça peut
justifier la dame en d2 puisque sur g5
on peut envisager des coups comme f4
voire des coups comme h4 avec une dame
qui peut pénétrer plus tard dans le camp
un noir puisque ici regardez j'ai 5 h 4
et que font les noirs difficile si on
joue elle un coup comme h6 bon on
affaiblit les cases toutes les cases
blanches autour du roi noir on peut il
envisager des dames 2 damage 5 et
attaque attaque sur le renoir
donc ça peut être dangereux pour les
noirs très vite aussi il faut faire très
attention
donc là carsen bardi ceux qui jouent
tranquillement pour entrer dans la
finale cavaliers prend 1,6 et si les
blancs prennent du plomb f pas du pion
des mets sur psyko tour da silva en
prennent du plomb f
c'est possible mais dans ce cas-là bon
mais y'a plus rien la tour 1 ici elle
est bloquée par le pion on peut plus
attaquer le roi noir tout de suite et
puis le pion de d5 est faible on va
pouvoir doubler les tours attaqué ce
pion des cinq rajouter pourquoi pas la
dame à l'attaquant par exemple d'un b5
et on attaque encore plus le pion des 5
et s'il tombe tout la position blanche
tombe c'est un pion central ça serait
extrêmement grave et le pion à aussi
sans plus bush aurait la colonne alors
donc un an de joux tour prend 2,6 et là
c'est pas la même chose parce que si les
noirs prennent avec la tour on prend
sans doute du pion des ce qui libère la
force des deux pièces blanches sur la
colonne des avec possibilité de
pénétrantes 17 le roi noir qu'est faible
et toujours ce prime time qui menace de
prendre un g6 aussi pour affaiblir leur
ont donc sans doute on prendra ping
n'est donc les noirs ne prennent pas
échec d'abord de quartiers noirs des
attaques et je sais qu'on la croie b1
donc sociologique pas de problème est
maintenant tour s'est vite
attention menace des noirs tout reprend
pions et oui parce que si tout reprend
pions des noirs dans prend dame ces deux
échecs 3 à 1 dames c'est un échec tout
reprend tout reprend mat
donc attention tout reprend pions avec
attac de maths
attention la même si pour l'instant au
contrôle on est surchargé ici on peut
pas défendre à la fois la première
rangée et le pion dessins qu'il faut
trouver quelque chose pour eux ici
l'idée de danone ici tout un sait qu'en
cas de tout reprendre des cinq surtout
pas prendre puisqu'il ya toujours la
menace d'armes ces deux échecs suivies
d'oedèmes série matt
mais en cas de tourcoing ont fait
toutefois cet échec ans et c'est pas la
même c'est pas la même puisque on va
prendre la dame et on aura il y aura
deux tours emprise la tour des 5es à
tours s'est vite donc même si les noirs
prennent reprennent la dame ils vont
perdre une tombe donc la menace est
reprendre cette attention pour car c'est
ni donc tout reprend tour car c'est le
plus simple on prend et regardez l'ours
est pas la même puisque si on prend bien
sûr on peut prendre du plombier comme on
l'avait eu tout à l'heure mais là on est
plus on n'a plus les double tour sur la
colonne des donc les noirs reviendrait
sans doute avec tour des huit essais les
noirs qui contrôle la colonne voilà et
le pion aux six bon ben il est protégé
par f5 mais on va essayer de pilonner 5
on va essayer de par exemple jouer des
coups comme dame c5
après avoir attaqué là il faudra tout
que la dame trouve une case et puis on
va attaquer le 5 et 6 n 5 tombeur 6
tombe aura aussi donc il ya tout qui
tombe fait donc là il faut surtout pas
prendre du plomb donc là allant de bay
hill voilà ils se trompent pas ils
prendre la tour heureusement tour des
huit attaques
maintenant ici bien sûr tout de suite
bassin pions isolés on va l'empêcher
d'avancer
voilà on bloque dame eu trois toujours à
limiter tout à l'heure en menaces ont
fait une contre menace d'un an 10,6 sur
la case de 7 et avec échec et perte de
la dame tour 17 protection de car ses
draps des très solides
regardez toujours pas de faiblesses d'un
compte car scène même s'il est un peu
resserré ses structures de pions il a
deux îlots contre un deux trois quatre
îlots pour les blancs ça veut dire il ya
quatre cibles du côté noir possible et 4
ensemble depuis on regarde et même le
dam d'ailleurs mais à un petit oeil
maintenant sur h2o 6-1 pas parlé tout à
l'heure mais on peut prendre hd à tout
moment là ça va pas forcément intérêt de
le faire pour l'instant puisque cette
saurait tomberez sur ce qu'est le drap
noir qui serait faible mais c'est quand
même il faut avoir cette idée en tête
voilà alors que les blancs que deux deux
attaques sur cet îlot là sur cet îlot la
dame notamment trois attaques le pion
ici et là des six alors ça c'est bien
des six est intéressant peut pas prendre
de la dame puisqu'elle à tours on peut
apprendre de la tour parce qu'ils
auraient tout reprend échec et la dame
est perdu et il reste la prise du pion
forcé parce que sinon bien sûr on prend
2,7 avec le pion et là c'est les blancs
qui gagne donc là on reprend on a
sacrifié on a rendu en quelque sorte
puis enfin on l'a pas rendu on la donne
et on a donné ce pion mais on a un pion
isolés ici et ont gardé l'idée allende
qui est joli c'est pas mal simplement
dans des cas de centralisation gardien
revient des quatre dames 1 elle était
partie en d2 en e3 elle revient en d4
dans nos centres c'est toujours bien et
je menace d'un principe six échecs au
roi avec un massacre donc le roi est
sous pression il faut absolument
protéger ce pion névralgique ici par
tours fc est hélas simplement puis on
prend g6 pourquoi pas puis on prend et
simplement tout reprendre et 6 on
récupère le pion on contrôle la colonne
des les noirs sont passifs avec leur
tour puisqu'ils contrôlent à 6 alors qui
est mieux ici c'est difficile à dire
peut-être d'un point de vue structurel
on peut dire que les noirs sont mieux
puisqu'ils ont deux îlots de pions
toujours contre 3 mais regardez les
blancs déjà ils ont plus que doublé
ils ont réussi à assainir un peu le
structurer pions très important mais
c'est des pions doublé c'est bien
doubler certes ceci dit ces pions
peuvent quand même aller attaquer le roi
noir essayer de casser la protection des
rois noir et par ce biais là tenté de
faire des échanges qui saignait la
position à 6 empêche simplement ben
enlève la tacc de la dame sur le plus
riche est même si techniquement bon
c'était pas possible puisque la tour des
six est attaqué mais bon à six a assaini
sa solidifie là les deux pions à 3 de la
part d'un homme grand perdant de ce
ménage un petit espace ici pour l'euro
on sait jamais un plus tard dans la
partie
l'atalante damas m alors attention ici
parce que la structure noir bien sûr et
très solide très difficile à attaquer et
lasser car ce n est dans son élément il
en fait une partie y trouve des petits
des petites façon d'améliorer sa
position
damas cinq bon pourquoi pas attention il
peut y avoir bombé pourquoi pas un échec
quand même cinq bons même si c'est pas
forcément extrêmement fort ses pions
sont quand même voilà c'est des pions
isolé f4 dans la part des langues
pourquoi pas alors dans les commentaires
on pouvait voir que certains se demander
pourquoi pas acheter
oui pourquoi pas acheter at on aurait pu
aussi est hantée h4 à noter que de toute
façon et ses deux pions même f4 attaque
pas directement le roi noir puisque la
dame ici contrôle ainsi donc en cas
d'avancé on prendrait de la dame avec
une position solide et enfants de plus
donc il faut faire attention donc ici
damages 5 voilà deux cars scène voilà
l'idée dans le car simplement venir h5
je contrôle le pion m6 je contrôle la
case f5
j'empêche des poussées et j'attaque le
pion h 2
j'attaque le plus proche d'eux je me
balade la dame est libre en fête puisque
tout est solide ici et les blancs ils
peuvent continuer à faire pression mais
pour continuer à faire pression sur six
faut pas bouger
donc ça c'est une pression qui vous
oblige à rester un peu immobile alors
bon c'est un peu un peu spécial donc à
nantes voilà un an d'ici défend mais ce
faisant ils attaquent plus f6 donc il
libère la tour eiffe cette dame c'est 5
de la part de carsen qui stresse pas
continuer là un petit oeil ici sur la
tour il peut menacer un échec quand j'ai
un bon il posé la question aux rois ou
tu vas est il pas là d'un peu il essaie
d'améliorer pression de ses pièces tour
des cinq attaques la dame mais en fait
d'un tour des simples qu'on enlève
encore une fois de la pression sur m 6
dames ces quatre ans des comices balade
ici dams et 4 pourquoi pas atteint à un
oeil sur la tour menaçants et fin tour
17 tours 17 d'un an d'ici maintenant
clouage de la tour donc échanges
possibles à nantes veut simplifier la
position c'est vrai que ça va être très
difficile à gagner s'il ya que les dames
puisque les pions son édition équilibré
pour les noirs bon ici
ce tour 17 signe un peu peut-être la fin
de la partie
dams et si ce temps des six noms à
nantes continue en fait là non de ce
qu'il cherche encore à gagner 3 à 2
tours cette voie là non c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure le fait d'avoir
bougé les pièces fait que voilà on
libère cette fameuse tour à seller pour
qu'arsène il libère sa tour puisqu'elle
si ce n'est plus vraiment attaqué en k2
dames c'est trois quatre récits
simplement prend f4 avec la dame on perd
un point avec les blancs puisque on
protège m6 et on a pris le pion et
attention donc dame c1 il faut trouver
des coûts et les noirs et c'est pas
facile dames c'est un à cinq ans yves
carcelle à cinq or c'est quoi l'idée à 5
mais ça c'est de venir à 4 puisque en
étant à quatre on contrôle la casse b3
donc on enferme un peu le roi blanc et
en cas d'échec sur la diagonale
ici à 2
g8 eh bien on pourra pas jouer b3 on
pourra faudra interposés une pièce où m
leroy sur la première avec des
possibilités des chèques sur le couloir
le fameux couloir donc si c'est fait
pour en enlever de l'air au roi blanc un
set cette idée la dame et fin de la part
d'anonymes et sa dame ici sur casse
blanche puisque c'est les cases blanches
qui risquent d'être faibles il l'a mis
sur caisse blanche
donc on va pouvoir contrôler les cases
lors sans doute pas la case h3 mais
peut-être ce venir soit sur détroit soit
sur b5 éventuellement sur ces 4 quand la
dame si la dame noire bouge de façon à
contrôler les cases blanches et éviter
d'éventuels échecs sur cette diagonale
et tout en ayant ici un oeil sur le pion
f4 à 4/4 scène continue par des sons sa
petite prise davantage un petit peu là
voilà ils lancèrent un peu laurent blanc
les blancs sont un petit peu moins bien
à cause de ses pions qui sont quand même
un peu faiblard 1 ils sont ils sont
isolés sont ils sont pas reliés entre
eux donc ils sont moins forts tour d un
regarder les blancs là un homme préfère
aller défendre sa première rangée mais
on voit bien que c'est un coup passif
voyez un petit peu un petit peu moins
bien finalement après l'attaqué un hand
après avoir essayé de prendre un petit
avantage
il a hésité à rentrer en finale tout à
l'heure et voilà ce qui lui arrive voyez
comme quoi il faut être précis attention
ici un dame ces deux attaques à la fois
h2 menace tour b3 menace aussi bête
tours 2 1
qui peut être dangereux attention quand
même s'il ya des contre attaques blanche
tondez cet échec
si le roi bien h6 il peut y avoir des
dommages trois matches donc c'est
attention hein il ya quand même il faut
faire un faux très prudent tour des
quatre de l'appartenance à leur tour des
quatre avec l'idée sans doute
1 pourquoi pas devenir en c4 avec la
dame qui est la dame en c4 et bien
attaquera le pion à 4 et propose
d'échanger dunkerque tour deux menaces
matt direct voilà très simple voyez
comme carsen et en plus c'est donc sa
bouche
la diagonale blanche donc là que fait
heins et aubin
heureusement il s'en sort par le joli
tour b quatre attaques bessette a noté
attention parce que les noirs en
attaquant c'est toujours le danger dans
ce genre de finale
si on attaque on se découvre donc il
faut toujours peser le pour et le contre
1 parce que attention si tomber cet
échec le roi noir lui même finir par
être faible la tombe écarté très bien
ici puisque allah ta'ala un oeil sur à 4
elle a un oeil sur bessette
elle a un oeil sur la case c4 qui est
toujours qui peut toujours être embêté
en tant qu à deux tours ces quatre
échecs
donc on empêche des siècles de l'adar
mon contrôle aussi la casse b3 elle est
magnifiquement placée puisqu'elle est en
plus protégés par le pion à 3,6 en doute
sa meilleure case et en plus le contrôle
et 4,7 hors île magnifique
voilà lé défensive est attaquant on l'a
très bien ou très bon placement des
pièces d'un an d'ici et là simplement
bessengue mais sur faut pas laisser tout
reprendre cet échec alors à noter ici
que tout reprend bessengue ne marche pas
puisque la dame viennent ces quatre
échecs au roi et attaques de la case b5
donc intact de la tour saga dream tour
et puisque dans le premier cinq on
continue de garder un oeil sur le tour 2
donc les noirs les blancs pourrait pas
se venger sur la tour et demi donc
attention attention et le piège il faut
surtout pas bien surprendre baissé et la
jolie coude à nantes sans double cookies
qui lui permet d'assurer la nulle
maintenant puisque c'est lui là qui
cherchent un peu le nul à cause de ses
pions peu faiblard là
ici dames 1 h un très joli menace
simplement d'un bep cet échec est soit
pourquoi pas la prise du pion b5
quoique attention puisque bien sûr il y
aurait aussi des possibilités de faire
tout re 1 pour les blancs pour les noirs
pardon suivi de fée des dents mais un
échec et puis on peut poursuivre le roi
laurent blanc peut être un peu peut-être
le maté attention mais ça peut être
l'idée de prendre en bessin de prendre
de la tour ans à 4 par exemple pourquoi
pas ça peut être ça c'est quand même une
idée et et puis où va le roi noir mais
sûr qu'on va leur endroit
parce que si le renoir va se voir la
huitième on voit bien que il peut se
faire mater très vite aussi et si v sur
la case h si ça peut être dangereux
aussi
donc tour cette voie là personne ne
laisse pas faire dam des scènes re
centralisation de nouveau de la monnaie
tout à l'heure c'est un des quatre
nations des cinq centralisation de la
dame attaque du pion faible b5 ces infos
c'est un point faible
très nettement tout re 1 c'est ce que
j'avais dit leur attention la contre
attaque tourer menace maths et la très
certainement parce que tout est bien en
on est obligé de prendre la nulle
esquisse qui va faire part d'amd cet
échec regarder si le roi va sur la
huitième on continue de faire des
chèques avec la dame et s'il vient sur
h6 bien sûr c'est damas trois échecs et
3g cette dame 17 et les deux joueurs ont
convenu de la nulle part échec
perpétuelle dans cette position puisque
les noirs menace maths et les blancs
menace d'échecs successifs le roi noir
qui ne peut pas s'échapper voyez que si
lyon qui vient h6 il se prend à damas
trois obligé de revenir
hélas il va sur la huitième c'est pareil
en veulent poursuivre par des échecs
simplement il faudrait remettre la tour
en défense si on voulait éviter
avec le risque de se faire contre
attaque et donc certainement pas partie
nulle dans cette première partie donc
premiers enseignements pour ce
championnat du monde est bien anne on a
réussi quand même une belle ouverture et
sans doute il a manqué les charges des
dames on l'a vu
on va peut être revenir juste sur ce
passage sans doute le moment crucial
malgré qu'il était sans doute légèrement
surpris de la variante choisie par
carcelle le moment de crucial ici on
revient sur la partie très certainement
c'était avant pardon voilà ici dans
cette position voilà à nantes a joué le
ku'damm des deux au lieu de rentrer dans
une finale alors peut-être parce que
justement il sait que car ce n est très
fort en finale est toujours un peu
embêtant mais sans doute c'était le coup
de prendre un b 6 apprend b et roye b a
tout simplement tour c'est elle et non à
les bleus n'auront pas le temps
d'empêcher tour si un tour c'est cette
peuvent essayer de jouer cavalier des 8
mai pour y changer le fou mais bon il y
avait du jeu pour les blancs et
peut-être possibilité d'essayer de
chercher quelque chose dans cette
variante
on verra donc ce qui va se passer dans
la partie où un endroit de nouveau les
blancs
en attendant bien sûr on verra la
deuxième partie où sait qu'arsène qui
joue avec les blancs pour la prochaine
voilà merci de m'avoir suivi sur sept ce
petit compte rendu rapide 1 2 car senna
nand et je vous dis à bientôt